lucas giolito going to the mount here
tonight for the white sox and again he
handled these tigers pretty handily the
first time around 13 strikeouts it was
the game before the no-hitter geoleto
against victor reyes
to start a friday night and a swing and
a miss for strike three that's out
number one first strikeout for lucas
giolito and that'll bring up jonathan
scope and the 2-2 a swing and a miss for
strike three back-to-back strikeouts to
start things off
so here is candelario
strike three away with him and lucas
giolito
strikes out three and casey mize the
youngster who made his big league debut
right here in this ballpark that same
night against the chicago white sox you
know he hasn't really gone deep in any
game so brayu with a 22 game hitting
streak that is a career high for him
obviously they're a great lineup this
guy among the best in the game right now
but even that
good movement right
jonathan scope retires jose abreu and
that's a very efficient seven pitch
frame
willy castro to lead off the tigers
second
high fastball it's been a pleasure four
strikeouts for lucas giolito and four
outs tonight and here comes daz cameron
swaying in the midst there's strike
three that is five strikeouts for lucas
giolito
now he sucked paredes no score two on
second inning and the one one is hit in
the air to right center field tracking
that one out luis robert he glides under
that one reaches up and makes the grab
and the inning has come to an end
so the tigers put a couple of men on via
base on balls but come off empty two
away the bases are empty
that'll bring up luis robert robertson
in 265 playing great defense 2-2 pitch
swinging a miss fastball got him up
above the strike zone at 95. pardon
pitching right there had him set up
perfectly he's dialing it up omar mizara
still in search of home run number one
with the white sox here's the one 1-2
and mazara
did not go
angel didn't signal oh he did go
he's walking back to the dugout second
strikeout of the night for casey mize
that's one out here in the white sox
third that'll bring up gilmer sanchez
playing over to third base tonight the
wind up the two two swing and a miss he
got him in the fastball casey mize
dialing it in has struck out three in a
row all swinging that'll bring up jose
abreu that career-high 22-game hitting
streak here on the line the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss he got him down and
away terrific we head to the fifth and
there's no score in the game
lucas giolito working here at austin
romine
struck him out change up on two and two
fluttered off the plate that'll bring up
james mccann mize works first base side
the 2-2 swing and a miss he got him with
another curveball down and away mccann
strikes out strikeout number five two
outs in the fifth that'll bring up luis
robert robert at the plate just struck
out his first time up he swings and hits
a high fly ball right center not deep
cameron over will call off reyes make
the catch and through five innings casey
mize has faced the minimum 15 batters
fantastic one base runner was eliminated
that base runner reached on a walk
now the bases are loaded with nobody out
and the batter willy castro two and two
swinging a missed strike three
that was buried in the sand and giolito
gets his first out of the inning one owl
base is loaded when afasio steps to the
plate with one out bonifacio waiting the
one-two swinging a fly ball center field
right to robert will he get the run home
he makes the catch tagging scope coming
home throw to the play will be cut off
on the mound sacrifice fly for bonifacio
gets scope in and the tigers take a
one-nothing lead in the sixth good
situational hitting it was a fast ball
got a lot of the plate as cameron steps
to the plate it'd be a great time for
his first
major league hit cameron wedding this
will be the eighth pitch of the at-bat
again the 3-2 pitch swinging line drive
base hit into right field
cabrera into score candelario right
behind him first major league hit for
dez cameron a two-run single
three-nothing tigers so two men on for
esau paredes again madrigal shades up
the middle but he doesn't fully shift
and the pitch on the way grounded to the
left side will be fielded by sanchez
he'll throw it a second they'll get the
force
and the ending has come to an end but
not before some damage is done by the
tigers they score three times on three
hits and that'll bring up yomer sanchez
it is three nothing detroit here in the
sixth inning two and two
sanchez right hand side fair down the
line
mazar
on his way to third nomar mazzara gets a
stop sign at third and runners it's
second and third there's your first hit
tonight and the sox are in business in
the sixth well right now madrigal's job
with nobody out get him over and get him
in
second base gets a run home madrigal the
rbi ground out scoring masara and yolmer
sanchez to third some runners at the
corners
and though jimenez at the plate
illinois hits it high in the ear deep
left field way
up and out of here bring him home
and bring the socks
a three
run home run given the lead 4-3
a towering fly ball
and that one just didn't come down until
the sox had the lead
and two on now with two outs and here is
jose abreu
22 games in a row with a hit for jose
abreu the longest of his career
34 shy
of joe dimaggio well we've seen him
so many times keep it alive in his last
at-bat ground ball off the end of the
van to candelario big hop as he moves to
the glove side he'll make the play
unassisted crosses the bag with his left
foot and heads right into that tigers
dugout last shot for the tigers as
zabrayu grounds out with two men on we
head to the ninth inning 4-3 chicago
victor reyes steps to the plate last
hope for the tigers
two and two
he struck him out in the sox win the
opener